every evening thirty-year-old our dish
sits in the spot watching television
this is not his home he does not have
one
but Delhi's cold and polluted winter
nights are a bit easier to bear in this
government shelter for the homeless it's
comfortable here I come here watch TV
fall asleep
I came to Delhi because I can earn more
here I can work hard all day in the
village but earn very little
adesh came to Delhi when he was just 14
years old to try to earn money for his
father's tuberculosis treatment now he's
the sole wage earner in his family of
three making two to three dollars a day
working odd jobs on construction sites
as the night wears on the shelter starts
filling up with migrant laborers like
adesh some spots still lie empty but
this does not mean there are no more
people out in the cold as temperatures
dip and the city passes them by
thousands of homeless people in Delhi
tried to find a corner to call home for
the night just a 5-minute walk from our
day shelter this bridge is a popular
spot a sealed-off portion under it is a
home for many families 50 year old
lalanne has been coming to Delhi for two
decades the youngest of his six children
lives with him here in the day the
shelter nearby serves as a makeshift
school for her but she and her mother
cannot spend the night there as the
shelter is only for men alcoholics
addicts stay in the shelters they fight
they do other things how can I take my
little children here we don't have a
home to live with our kids to educate
them keep them clean where's our place
under this bridge that's all for the
last 20 years we've been lying here
last month LaLanne developed a cough
because of the pollution and cold he
earns 10 to 20 rupees roughly 25 cents
for every errand he runs but missing a
day of work means missing crucial wages
to support his family of eight none of
Leland's so-called neighbors believe
there is a better alternative some don't
know about the government shelters
others find them insecure his children
have grown up under this bridge
but Lenin still dreams of a better
future for them we don't want our kids
to end up like us
we want them to get good jobs good homes
and want them to become good human
beings for the coming month however the
only goal will be to stay warm
[Music]